Maddie I need you to think about what
you just did what do you think many what
did you just tell oh you don't know what
you did tell him what you did let me
sing it for you
Maddie took a bet killed poop that's all
I got was a recipe think about what you
just did think about what you did the
struggle is real we took him to the vet
this morning and I mean honestly I you
know I don't want to say that like he
he's definitely brought my life much joy
but I've also never uh you know thought
that I was gonna lose my mind you know
Oh panic attack II a because I think my
dogs eating his body
let's put Maddie down for a nap and then
we'll go get some lunch let's put him in
his cage great you look damn cute
Sabrina I are reliving when she came out
to visit me a long time ago in like 2011
April 2011 I've been here why I came
with predator yeah like six that Bryan's
ever been here probably 2007 Regas 2006
I moved her in 2007 okay yeah Oh coffee
date I agree I do I'd like a nice to
something so yeah this is great
just taking some tours took Matthew the
fed earlier pooped in Petco we are what
is not the touristy but I should take
them to do probably like a Hollywood
sign we've got a lot of in Bella's it's
meetings like you've done them
but it's like I what I heard up quote
over here I swear I don't drink I don't
I say I haven't drank since Jenna's
party Jenna's party Jenna's party I know
I don't
we actually don't drink I don't we
talked about partying a lot but our idea
of parting is sitting and doing nothing
I dropped that that's dangerous team dog
wait seoeon Gracie are inconsiderate
okay
sure all days everybody gotta talk like
I got something today okay
Lamar know that when you learn with it
all right we gotta get it we gotta get a
cake for batard it is it is the pitar
party where are you turning up not here
yes she was 15 right yep totally is
totally is so exciting I wonder what
kind of lecture we're gonna have more on
significant give up those like he's got
at a living kasha money's good as
Dorothy in here my gosh
unfortunately that's just what he looks
like right now gluten-free vegan
we should get a vegans
purpose show
using names yeah bummer yeah that's
great let's do those have been earth
they covet are the little size bizarre
that's good enough that's good what's
good looks nice
that's great I don't think I could have
done this better
huh you guys see my cooking skills I'm
decided today that he was gonna be the
cake delivery man we had a wild day
today we did a lot of things well I
didn't accomplish any of the work that I
plan on getting done so we ended up
being gone for a really long time so
that's all right
I had fun a good time with green and Bry
Jenna wasn't there she missed out on the
fun Matt wasn't there either
they were babysitting the puppy just for
a little itchy man
we're going to have more nights here at
Universal I've actually never been here
we're gonna get some food first what do
you guys feel like now okay
yo what's up yeah what you guys want I'm
Davey to see the shot of our deal we're
really turning up here guys
we're about to go into the Halloween
Horror Nights really good Azzam because
I've actually never been good for
superhero we're ready it's gonna be more
sweet at dinner he's backing out yeah
you're driving no shots for you hey
general yeah did you over babe hey black
over there you know Wow mommy's all
tonight
Mylo man
Wow
this is not okay
I am NOT okay idea I thought okay she
might not be okay
parallels it cuts you all she's not well
see
no she's actually not angry I'm like
don't touch me you're going at me with a
chainsaw
Oh
we survived it
I'm I am honestly like I wanna breathe
oh dude
poor baby let's go let's go no touching
no touching
don't touch me thank you I think you're
allowed to be touched for like in
various parts really like like all over
Oh Universal speaking of the bruised
hand out good foot hurts
Breanna great I'm gonna get part she
made us really
that was not okay
on the water yo what about this donut
though
bring her leg about back up I right now
right now but yeah you're gonna shock
that you're good take a bite
my lady my mouth he's got some Duff
energy P I'm really good 1 2 3
yeah yummy let's go just cuz he actually
shooting other hands I'm all ready for
the picture not me I want my phone
I can't like threaten center what kind
of fool in the dark
what you said in it when you say it's
chilled out frappe chilled out
I think it's real whack oh hey Bri we
just said him in store 11 the other
class was actually really good
I like we did well the other day that
wasn't that good and you could tune into
a classifier it's very disappointed you
like
this is a great one so now we're gonna
go meet Jenna first getting is coffee
I can't wait hi uncle all I heard Jenna
vlogging bad don't be dirty look I've
got clean new sheets do not sit on my
bed okay you're you're mine oh go
Bree Bree Bree when I left off last we
were at yoga and we said we were gonna
go to a class with Jenna canceled see
yep
it's you Jenna wait sharing bunker sorry
we are gonna go kayaking now kind of
excited we have been wanting to do this
for a really long time and now we're
finally doing we're about to go kayaking
and I didn't go by myself so Bree or
Jenna who's right whose ride was your
something because we're going to be
filming I'll go so then so like should
we both should we go together like maybe
because I can take a turn to flip film
okay thank you guys this is good idea
yeah Bree all by herself this is gonna
be fun it's really high heat we sure on
top in Bray pop in genuine front or back
I'll go in the back which one does more
work I'll take the front
how's the boating going free Wendy
Lucia kayaking on my mind
well now that I'm in town for a little
while quite excited about it sea lions
we had to get a little closer do you
think okay I've got my camera so I can't
can't just paint much or so ii can't
tell cuz the black we're gonna go there
are nails on now I want to get a nice
blue color I said it before go to get
our nails done well you end up posting
vlogs way before me anyway so somebody
said oh my gosh de chine and Jenna both
posted Halloween videos and Justine
posts a two-minute unboxing of an amiibo
stand I'm like yeah that sounds about
right
I had that films like a week or two ago
and was all I had it edited this was
just this car real fancy what your your
rough fancy so we're gonna go okay well
well your car looks good sir
oh my god I want to get on here I really
don't know them
mommy's out tonight mommy's out today
let's put him down let's see what his
outfit is before my battery dies Maddie
let's see it put it down let's see your
outfit come on you want to chew my
finger put him down
you've got your polo on he's been so
much better he didn't even like him I
don't want to jinx it but he did not
even bite his paws since we've taken a
sec - you look so cute he's like he's
got his dress shirt on his Saturday fine
he does you're wearing your dress shirt
shirt so you can hang out with the boys
and use the easel in a bite on my hoe to
a shower just like today's so summery
sunroof sunroof chillin oh he's so cute
my baby oh my god what do you think
yeah it's up for his the first boys
night those pants are sick Thanks are
you gonna do it after the day no get a
youtube shirt yeah I'm gonna stop
vlogging now oh yeah I know you're
walking guys we'll be right back
we just saw that there is a guitar
available at Best Buy and we are in an
emergency dire situation to get another
guitar for rock band so they'll be able
to play bass you guys you better be
ready tonight to play
I thought the news home separately we
made it we made what like 20 minutes to
spare like this isn't even a big deal
and Steve Fuuka has his drink and his
lorry owes he's like I don't want to be
done with my drink or my snack I thought
you were joking when you said you were
bringing a snack thank you haha I never
joke about food you know neither does
grey well actually I don't either but
I'm trying to not eat too many Oreos
okay let's go get our toy
oh that's a great amigo case
toys cement with any battery this is
what I need I also need this
wait is that just the OU grads for Xbox
yeah they tell you good that didn't sell
them like this before I don't know I'm
not sure it doesn't matter we got it
haha that's a big box I want to get a
big fire pit wait they have like
furnitures I didn't know this where are
we
we're in the Homewood section of Best
Buy this is insane
I've got tons of appliances over there
Joe I know I got my washer/dryer I also
got my frigerator but I didn't know they
had like this what is this this is great
how does this work
if I were to get this how does that work
I can no longer carry anything else what
did we get it right now I mean you know
for the future is it gas like yeah hook
it up to a gas line just just work ah
there'd be like a propane tank maybe
patty Alonzo that's too much we just
want that's not what's in here
look at this this is so nice we thought
what we want to know you got your shoe
put your snack we're really really
testing it out in a living how is it the
guy do you think it's nice
mm-hmm cool do you like it
do you think it looks dumb
yeah that's good the whole point in
wanting to get a case is not get a clear
one so you won't see a graph it gets
stuck behind the clearcase but
I like it though I like what does all
the stabilization so like you're going
to fight it at first but in reality it's
doing everything for you you don't have
to do anything except push your weight a
little bit for to go fast or push a
little back to go backwards like bring
you're doing everything really well
you're doing better than anyone I've
ever seen oh it was good that was good
good really well opposed to the glass
you know that would be great yeah
really well what a fun time wait don't
leave Bridal in what way back next how
we greeted see not fun I'm so sad breeze
leaving this vlog is coming to a close
no my TV I did a lot of things in this
video a lot of things um okay I'll see
you whenever you I have to go to sleep
for like 24 hours this is really big
this is a lot bigger than I thought it
looked a little smaller on the internet
that usually tends to happen